so in 1975 my mother and my father got
married 11 years later they had me
we've always been asked things like how
did you get started on YouTube how do
you get started in filmmaking and we
don't really have the exact answers to
that but hopefully through our
discussions here you might find some
answers if your honor something very
special happened in Minnesota many years
ago my dad got a really nice camera for
the time that is it shot 720 by 480 whoo
and you know it's it's the kind of same
situation where you have a friend who
gets an n64 or he or I guess damn it's
funny you know 2015 here so your friend
gets a ps4 and you really want to play
it here like hey I really want to play
with your ps4 the camera I had 15 years
ago was kind of like that it was like oh
my god you got one of those cool cameras
let's shoot some stuff with it he can
issued some stuff with it and before I
knew it
we're shooting a lot of stuff with him
and that was how Sam got his first
friend
that's not my first friend I was like a
knee and he goes like hey can I use your
camera to shoot some stuff and I was
like hey can i play your n64 that's good
let me learn how to build pcs together
and they peacefully shook hands in the
middle of the street Sam I start
shooting videos together back in ninth
grade
we shot a sour Sam which finally after
15 years hard work
saw the light of day on YouTube yeah
it's crazy distribution hell and that
was the first four I'd like visual
effects and shooting and from there like
the summer was spent researching all the
cool programs out there for making
videos and really wait you take
Photoshop and you draw a muzzle flash on
one of the frames and you put that in
the video it looks like a human gun
sweet transformers here we go
yeah it's suddenly and then uh currently
airsoft guns were like a becoming a
thing at that time - this is is this
like 2001 mind you like airsoft guns
literally didn't exist before the year
don't fact-check that but the point is
is that they were on eBay and I was like
basically since the sixth grade I was
like a really upstanding eBay member and
then suddenly airsoft guns exist I'm
like wait a second
no one knows how old I am on eBay and
the stores won't sell them to me because
I'm not 18 yet I'm ever that so then I
was like Desert Eagle high off the
matrix here so got some desert eagles
and stuff and boom suddenly we got some
videos just like that reading Sam Sam's
like arguments with people on eBay
oh yeah like the broom mm yeah they're
still there really funny a lot of
percent positive feedback that's why
King me first
oh one an asset to the eBay community
recommended a a plus plus plus with us
Sam replies thank you thanks guys never
deal with again
watch out users Sam's apply you're
stupid wait what I don't know why that
would have been a thing
hey guys an idiot 15 years later yeah so
Jake actually went to the same school we
just weren't really close friends I
guess Jake was one of those cool kids
who didn't mess around with cameras yeah
stupid cameras no that was just honestly
I was friends with like people on my
track team and and the sports teams that
I was on and that's actually how I came
to know Nico is he did cross-country
skiing with me would she like the star
athlete too well some would say but you
know we're talking everybody's brother
was on the yeah hey I took a couple of
his records yeah that's true anyway so
the clock quickly turned suddenly we met
Brandon and we made a bunch of explosion
videos and at the same school yeah I
knew Brandon before I really hung out
Jake and you burned your yard Oh Brandon
GI Joe yeah I read my are just a little
bit we burn Sam's driveway burned a lot
of Ryan's hair
although perhaps this is where our paths
were meant to cross because well you
guys were shooting videos or blowing
things up with Brandon I was also making
Molotov cocktails with my friend Jamie
Krantz
so there's kind of a trade-off there
yeah okay once you've learned how to
control fire mm-hmm
that's that's where things get good you
don't get scared of it anymore you're
going to tame it
you like that really the only power fire
has over you is here so wise yeah
so fast-forward four years through
college just a big blur anyways we're
out in Los Angeles Jake's okay tells us
upper Bowie you know how I got in touch
with them though is my mom my mom sent
me a newspaper clipping of Sam and Nico
in the hometown Gazette saying
filmmakers in Los Angeles and my mom
likes heads circled Nico's name and was
like you ran cross-country with him and
I was like yeah why are you sending this
to me I remember in the photo in the
Gazette and the hometown paper my mom
took in her like home photo studio
tonight of us like I'm like huh Michael
X hope holding like this little camera
gosh did you get the point down oh no
that's now it takes a decades to get the
point down I still haven't even Messi I
was just doing a point there guys I
could direct your attention over there
this this is a mature style how good a
director somebody is by how they point
so Jake was shooting with us cuz he
wanted to get this crazy movie world of
making videos about anyone else telling
you what to do
meanwhile he is stuck going to law
school and studying math he's like yes I
think I think he guys me a producer are
like yeah he's a producer we reduced it
for Jake's like nope like okay well
coming to our next set and we'll go from
there
Jake's like okay um and that I think the
first like shoot you're kinda like
helping on was a clocked walkers mm-hmm
well no not frozen crossing like our
first viral video Jake plays ghost take
a inspector I think he's like Jake's
actually really good physical activity
so that's pretty cool you should hone
our videos more often and turns out guns
are a theme and I said gladly yeah
although there's so there's a whole kind
of like this is the whole thing you're
skipping over the actual like kind of
forming of like some sort of I don't
know I mean you can say listen I rode up
one day and we're like let's like you
know yeah but I'm a business it wasn't
like that it was like there was a
classic story though that a lot of
people know and probably a bit actually
her
it out there which is you know we got
our start in actual freelance visual
effects artists yeah we did that for
about a year
during that we are year we are also
finishing up a feature film we're
working on and basically we put a bunch
of time and energy and effort into
making this stuff and making ends meet
if we when we were done it was like it's
over we made it
alright well no one's gonna see this for
about probably a year we had like
nothing to show for the year and a half
of work we just put into it we had
worked with Brandon and Freddie on it
and we saw their stuff take off or see
their kind of exploits on YouTube being
successful so we're like you know what
rather than wait a year to have someone
see some stuff we're making or share
that let's just make youtube videos
because apparently Google will give you
a couple cents on every view or whatever
it just got to make something that
people want to watch release it as fast
as we can
alright screw it we like video games
let's do modern warfare cuz that's a
popular game right made that released it
and we had no idea that it would be like
just explosive in how like the response
was so from there I'd be number one on
that well you're missing yeah what
Samsung but Sam's being humble about and
not saying here is that they also had a
lot of experience leading up to this I
mean you guys had done dark island you
guys had done green side you guys had
shot in a decent amount of stuff and and
you were applying that knowledge to this
so it wasn't like you just picked up a
camera and shot a video you know that
video did really well you're still
applying years of knowledge from when
these guys first started filming when
they were 14
up until that point so it's kind of like
everyone thinks oh how did Ben Stiller
and Matt Damon like get their start well
they wrote Good Will Hunting well but
actually they had done like a bunch of
stuff yeah up to that point it was good
filler yeah honestly we had been doing
filmmaking and all this stuff everything
from the visual effects to the sound and
blah blah blah we've been doing that for
about nine years before we even touched
YouTube so thing is is that if we were
fourteen we would be posting stuff on
YouTube too you know just that it wasn't
out so we'd spent those nine years
making our own funny little videos that
we up it up
uploaded to FX home you know or the the
hit film site as it's known written
right now so we made a YouTube videos
for a little bit and one day this car
rolls up on our street while we're like
doing stuff and Ren pops out of the car
we didn't know it yet but Ren pops out
of the car and comes up and it's like
hey guys like hey and Freddy's there and
Brandon's there I'm there he goes there
we're all hanging around and runs like
hey guys uh then we're like what's up uh
what's your name and he's like hey I'm
Ren I want to point out that I didn't
show up out of nowhere uh I was friends
with Henry from minutephysics at the
time his channel was like super tiny at
the time he had a car oh yes subscribers
but he was a the effects editor for
Freddy at the time and we've been
discussing just over email like all
summer and I was in town and it's like
hey mana wanted to hang out like he was
here with you guys and was like yeah
love to meet you guys too
it was Henry there yeah oh you're right
he was and they shot this photocell
video well quick quick side note I
actually saw a ran in a video that he
did it for the YouTube Nextup contest
and that's when I actually first I saw
uh hello next up thing yeah that video
is actually what ended up convincing me
to pursue this sort of career at all is
at the time I was like I was finishing
up an engineering degree and so it was
like you finish up a degree you usually
go into a career path with that degree
and I was finishing up and I kind of
realized I didn't really want to do that
I wanted to pursue this other stuff that
I had a much greater interest in and I
had no idea if I was good at all with
any of this stuff but I had just enough
of a positive reaction to that video in
the videos this small tiny videos I made
before that I was like you know what
I'll give it the summer I'll give it
like if he wants to see if I can make
anything worth of you know interest then
some time passed and we were kind of
breaking apart more and today of our own
studio Mars corridor digital Ren was I
guess looking to take part in things or
like you know what it's behind the
scenes things kind of neat we could
build a second channel etc etc
would you mind shooting some behind the
scenes for us and I remember when he
asked me that this is at VidCon in 2012
hey we wanted to shoot some
behind-the-scenes of those I guess I'll
do it I'm sure I've got nothing else to
do because I was like this is the
perfect opportunity to learn yeah
anyways made some really solid behind
the scenes nice thing was that you knew
a visual effects so you can make behind
the scenes into like visual effects
breakdowns which I think a lot of people
really liked there's nothing better than
seeing something that was boring and
then gone like psych it's amazing and
then you're just aa like omen was your
big step forward the visual effects it
was cuz that was the first time I was
like alright I'm gonna do all this stuff
I have no idea how to do it and I have
no idea how hard it's gonna that was
both like a bad thing and a good thing a
good thing in that I have no idea if I
had known how hard it was gonna be I
probably wouldn't have done yeah did I
remember watching a rough cut and like
let me take you like for months and
you're like I think I'd like to six
months later yeah differences that are
gone okay but I mean I learned how to
deal with so many different things on
that project um that was like finally
like okay I can kind of do some
high-level stuff to a certain extent and
I think that's when you guys lay all
right we can take you in and maybe start
learning some more things on top of that
ii know we're behind the scenes for you
right so the YouTube there was like
right back when like people are starting
to make a living off YouTube YouTube is
like you know we could probably
encourage this so I put together like a
grant program where you've been a give
you $30,000 which is a good chunk of
change the funny thing is so yeah it's
pretty main channel like oh my god we're
garde start like very had a year putting
out good content on the main childhood
will you go sand we Pro the main channel
like try to put a like on a Sunday or
some like that midnight so like no one
will see it and I hit the front page of
YouTube and do things we put into like V
like a random like people & blogs
category then it went on the front page
guys Christ sakes you know I'm really
bitter about that there's a really funny
video in fact it's and we were still
using the clips from that video in like
our current real we're talking we were
in contact with some people who were
about to receive some grants from
YouTube to make projects we were like oh
here's some cool ideas we'd like this is
one thing called tether we're working on
pretty cool and there's another thing
we're working on called sync so here's
some cool ideas and then I like
all right let's do both of them were
like yeah let's do both of them and then
a week later they're like okay we only
enough enough money for one of them
running okay we're gonna do tether and
like okay it's this much and we're like
okay we're gonna do sync pretty early
and they're like does that sound good
we're like yeah it does so we shook
hands and they're like cool you need to
shoot that uh in 30 days and we're like
okay so we just literally just came up
with the idea like last week are you
sure and they're like yes the first
episode you have to shoot in 30 days and
the first episode needs to come out in
like about 45 days like okay all right
cool um let's do this let's put this
together Jake was in law school during
that time having to produce this thing
in two weeks yeah and then you know all
do production while also going to class
that was my worst semester they put me
on academic probation and they sent me a
letter to my old address and I never got
it
and then at my new address after like I
did better the next semester they sent
me a letter signed by the Dean saying
congratulations you've been taking
you've been taken off academic probation
and then I took past the California Bar
Exam on my first try obviously the one
mistake that was made is that it was on
a monthly release schedule dumbest thing
ever never do that we didn't really have
an option but I don't care don't do it
it's if you want people to watch your
show and understand what's happening
don't release it once a month that's all
I'm saying it's it sounds obvious it's
like they won't care after a month
they'll just flat-out forget it ever
existed
yeah the closer you can get to
delivering it all at the same time so
that the viewer can decide when they're
want to watch it and how much they want
to watch at a time the better
exactly exactly the Netflix model yeah
basically yeah which is another thing
left a till very soon here with another
project I I don't know if you guys ever
realized this but you you guys like
literally saved me from moving away from
LA by hiring me like full-time because I
just finished oh man and I had something
like pretty much all of my savings into
that film and then I made a video for
South by Southwest and I was like the
rent that was like all the money I had
left
and that was like the cheapest video I'd
ever made and after that was like I've
got nothing and then you guys hey you
wanna come work on this Far Cry 4 video
I was like yeah let's do it and then
working ever since yeah this is
basically you when you start working on
omen
that's basically stop doing odd seems
pretty much yeah sounds like for Muslim
I was trying to do both at the same time
and then I realized if I want this video
to come out before the end of the year I
have to work on this like every day no
weekend's no weekends off I should say I
worked every every weekend and after six
months got that done and then did I
guess what was going on the second
channel during that time not unless John
was working where's Nadia well yeah and
we were we are we were read each other
like starting in December and then
through January February from a is just
tether tether tether tether for us
that's right they have finished a
feature-length script for tether yes I
mean connectors come in our first full
original script is just sitting there I
think we're gonna be doing another
feature like the projects before that
though hello watching Clinton Jones just
showed up the punisher clinical a story
tells the story about something what am
i walking into I'm doing comes going on
you just showed up he's not miked up at
all I remember one used to work out of
our studio yeah for the good old days I
remember playing video games never Daisy
Bayesian remember a archery lots of
archery oh and like the whole like BTS
thing was going down I like the equinox
you know everybody like we convinced
bread that like it was like or was Brett
told us he's awesome because the planets
are aligned oh yeah yeah oh you're
official pole pole that you like Sam it
was this just 2012 yeah like you know
you can just stand up a broom is it no
no no man we cool off
oh yeah he was so about that oh no
oh did you guys tell the story of the
time that we stopped the burglar that
robber ah we did not we didn't know him
he just yeah we redid a reenactment
we've you telegin here yeah what what is
this what are we what did I walk into
we're just talking about origins of the
channel and etc alright so when I first
met you all was when I came down here to
visit for three days and all we did was
go I walked in and like you guys playing
Minecraft you're talking about like
Minecraft
I was like yeah minecraft pretty cool
like I wasn't getting into it you know
but I wasn't really into it and like I
show up in like Sam and Nico or there
and like I remember Jimmy and Freddy
were there those are those are the four
that I remember right but I feel like
there are a couple more people there and
maybe like David Wells for someone I
don't know
Brandon once spent an entire week
building the Death Star in my back to me
that's what I wouldn't know there's
around the same time I wouldn't know I
know exactly like everyone hit like this
minecraft yeah and you built this
inverted pyramid thing yeah yeah it's
like why am i building it huh everyone's
like I'm gonna build like a statue and
I'm gonna build its castle and I was
like I'm a big inverted like
pyramid I'm super complex and I stood up
all night and like you guys woke up and
like I was still just like like isn't
there free mode like edible in its
really like yeah yeah so that was when I
met you guys so many guys shot her she
good friends yeah we shot that well yeah
but whether it was a sniper on the roof
from eating Cheetos so Clint where do
you think YouTube and online digital
streaming is going over the next few
years
well uh well YouTube's all jacked up now
YouTube is a fantastic platform that is
great for jump-starting things but it's
not an eventualities it's like knowledge
born yeah I think yeah I depends it's
really hard now like you can't just like
yeah it's because it's been out for
decades so it's just it's very saturated
/ celebrated and the only reason
honestly the only reason we're in the
pigeon
I'm wearing on YouTube is because of
when we started well yeah obviously
anything anything that anyone does that
they succeed at it requires a lot of
hard work I mean are we even real or is
this a bunch of CG stuff that the
government's putting out as propaganda
to make you make videos on YouTube or
whatever Emami
are just CG renderings but there's
someone else
whatever wondering this what actually
Ren was just a CG rendering he's like a
Jar Jar Binks that would be so creepy
like the way one other dude is just some
other random dude a green screen we hire
like these come and sit there and like
we track in our CG Ren and then lemony
Jian Ren needs to go to motion capture
for the whole interview oh you guys are
done I got another few hours to work on
this it's like it's like guys gonna be a
part of the this podcast it's like only
if you render yourself in yeah I don't
know if you guys know this but Ren is
actually short for render wait I have a
list online of Reds nicknames no no okay
we're not getting into that we get a
gate we can do nicknames there you go
that's this at the end of the video
we'll see you guys in the future let us
know if you want to see more of these
mmm